Film Courage: And you said one theater was
playing the film for over a year [without
your knowledge]?
Paul Sidhu: Yeah.
I heard about it.
I was kind of shocked.
Somebody…one of the guys who was actually
on the crew in India he called me up (I don’t
remember if he called me or emailed me).
He was like “Hey, Paul.
I just saw your poster here.
It’s still up and they’re playing the
film.”
And I was like “Nahh, you’re full of it.”
And I was like “Come on man.
Who is going to play that film for more than
a year?”
And he sent me a little picture and it was
up in the theater.
And I was like “Damn!
They’re playing my film.
It’s been up in the theater for like over
a year.”
So I decided to take a trip to go see like
what’s the story here?
Why do people like it?
It was a pleasant surprise.
The other thing that was also a pleasant surprise
was that first film was actually made it to
a lot of sources that I didn’t know about.
This is the funniest story.
So I told the theatrical rights.
I got money for the theatrical rights.
And that’s how we made our money.
But we didn’t sell our television rights.
So we’re shooting [Paul’s other film]
THE BLACK RUSSIAN up in the mountains and
there are only 2 channels.
And on one of the public channels they’re
playing AAKHARI DECISION and this is crazy.
So my crew (the make-up guy) he got sick.
So he was the only guy who was laid up in
the hotel.
And he was watching this and he sees my film.
And in India they just assume that…since
this is a film you’re starring in they just
assume “He’s a well-known actor.”
And so he goes “Oh, there’s another one
of Paul’s films, it’s on TV.”
So he recorded it on his cell phone and he
said “Hey, your film is playing.”
And I’m like “My film is playing?
What are you talking about?
No ones playing it.
This is my first film.
How can my film be playing.”
And he’s like “No your film is playing.”
So I go “Well show me.”
So he recorded it and my first film was actually
playing.
So we contacted the station.
We said “Hey who gave you the film?”
And they just didn’t answer the question.
So that was cool!
[Laughs]